où
moi
reposant à l'ecoute se sont n'est
pourtant pas destiné à vos oreilles mais
à votre cerveau et vos organes david
bakone sono thérapeute qu'ils utilisent
les sons pour équilibrer la circulation
d'énergie dans le corps c'est une
technique d'art trouver l'équilibré pour
une meilleure santé morale et meilleure
santé physique tout le travail de la
sono thérapie se trouvait la vibration
approprié pour harmoniser les vibrations
pour qu'il n'y ait plus de 10 à rosny
pour retrouve l'équilibré
une méthode thérapeutique qui agit au
temps sur le psyché que sur le physique
pour soigner le stress par exemple david
utiliser bol tibétain
ap les bols chantants on a tous une
énergie qu'on dégage d'une façon plus ou
moins large et donc les vols qui sont
sept métaux chacun des métaux va va
vibrer plus ou moins ce temps selon
l'état énergétique de la personne moi
j'aime résumé sans les ans selon les
creux et les bosses autre méthode
utilisée celle des diapasons ici david
parle de méridien comme une sorte
d'acupuncture sonore chaque note
correspond un point particulier le
musicien qui a mis en place cette
technique des diapasons qui fait bien
maman a trouvé une note pour chaque bien
présent donc de la même façon on la met
en vibration et on va le poser sur la
main sur le point qui est intéressant
pour la personne
voilà la sensation que j'avais c'était à
la fois d'être pris en charge et en même
temps d'avoir vraiment une direction
chaque chaque son chaque sensation comme
ça à chaque sont avec arrivant une vraie
volonté et ça ça m'a surpris en fait
même si la sono thérapie reste une
médecine douce non reconnue par
l'académie de médecine
plusieurs études ont déjà mis en avant
l' influence des sons et des fréquences
sur les organes